[Music]
Easter Island isn't the only place in
the world with some mysterious Stern
faces in the highest peak of the eastern
tourist mountain range in Turkey lies
nemrud dagh nemrut da is a temple tomb
believed to be built by the late
Hellenistic king Antiochus he reigned
from 69 234 BC and built the temple to
commemorate himself the monument
features statues of the king lions
Eagles and various Greeks
Armenian and Metis gods with each
measuring almost 30 feet tall
the heads of these sculptures once sat
atop their stone bodies but at some
point in time they were removed
nemrut doll went lost to memory until it
was rediscovered by a geologist in 1881
and in 1987 it was designated a UNESCO
World Heritage Site and while there are
those that believe these figures hold a
deep mythological significance how these
stone structures were physically
constructed without modern tools is a
mystery
you
at first glance visitors may not realize
that inside this mosque is a
multicolored secret
[Music]
located in Iran the Nasser almac mosque
is commonly known as the pink mosque due
to the rose-colored tiles that cover the
interior however this is far from the
only color found inside a wall of
stained glass windows turns the interior
into a rainbow Wonderland built in 1888
the Maus took 12 years to complete
now ceramic features plenty of
traditional Islamic architecture
elements such as the arches and the
central structure however the presence
of stained glass windows a design
element relatively rare for mosques
makes this particular Moss a unique and
stunning sight to see the stained glass
in the Cyril MOOC was built to catch the
morning sunlight as it reflects off the
walls and the brightly colored Persian
rugs on the floor
[Music]
the hope and intention was for the
colors to create a peaceful atmosphere
during early morning prayer the nasir al
McMath come as much of a destination for
visitors seeking the perfect photo as
those who still worship under the
rainbow of light in the Turkish region
of Cappadocia hidden in the hollowed
rocks lie some of the oldest Christian
churches in the world
the gorram open-air museum is a cluster
of monasteries and churches dating all
the way back to the 4th century 2.6
million years ago a volcanic eruption of
the nearby mount or shiz resulted in the
formation of mushroom shaped fairy
chimneys each church that makes up the
gorram open-air museum is housed within
a separate soft rock cave more than 10
churches make up the museum inside each
church are wall paintings known as
frescoes examples of old classics from
the Byzantine art period these
incredible paintings have managed to
retain their clarity and colors
throughout the years thanks to frequent
restorations
in 1984 the Gorham open-air museum
became one of the first two sites in
Turkey to be designated a UNESCO World
Heritage Site
but it's the museum's extensive history
and unique structures that have made it
one of Cappadocia is most visited
attractions when it's come to Iraq
people from outside the first image they
get war bloodshed kidnapping suicide
bomb all this violence you get through
the media then the reality is not like
that the beauty of our Tigers is this is
breathtaking
they remind you the Garden of Eden my
name is Nabil Moussa and I am a warrior
keeper Waterkeeper is the voice for
rivers our mission is keeping our
waterways swayable fishable drinkable I
am the first water keeper in the Middle
East I spent most of my childhood ride
by the river
catching fish playing with frogs and
that chasing dragonfly I have some
beautiful memories and I want to bring
them back the problems in an appetite
was River dams urban waste gravel mine
oil refinery and oil wells garbage from
picnickers my current mission is
educating people average raising
awareness and water quality monitoring
when the water gets polluted find out
how did that happen was a polluter I
made a lot of people's what I'm paddling
some people they are positive some
people they are negative they tell me
you are trying to you know stop all this
pollution we've been having them for for
years and years but our rivers are our
lifeblood and if we don't protect them
our life is not going to be safe I want
to raise awareness and tell next
generation action need to be taken I
want two people to go to nature more
appreciate the water more and to protect
I have a right to protect this water is
my water is everybody's water so I am
hopeful I am hopeful about the future of
Iraq and Kurdistan yes we won't get
located in Yemen is a palace that
appears to have been carved from the
rock that it sits on however this
man-made wonder was once just a simple
summer home just ten miles away from
Yemen's capital city of Sanaa is dar al
hajar al wise known as Iman's rock
palace in the early days of Yemen's
history the country was led by the Imam
the Islamic spiritual leader rather than
a king or president the rock palace was
built in the 1930s by Imam yaha as his
summer residence however it is believed
to have been built over an Oda palace
the residence is five stories high has
several balconies and its own water
supply from a deep well it is seen as an
example of traditional Yemen
architecture due to the patent windows
earth turn coloring and protruding
exterior decorations while tourism in
this region is limited due to conflict
this palace is both a sanctuary for
locals and an example of the man-made
beauty of Yemen
[Music]
just across the border from war-torn
Syria in a forgotten city is an
unexpected sight the hotel Palmyra
[Music]
this hotel is different than others
because time has washed away the walls
time has left us impact it is it is a
journey into the past so many people has
passed through this hotel this hotel has
been here since 1874 and this is why we
tried to keep it as it is the city of
velvet has changed of course it's
feeling the impact of the war on one
side of the borders but it's also
feeling the effects of economic
depression that's affecting the whole
country at one point there were no
visitors to speak of and that was very
difficult the hotel used to be a haven
for visitors because of the ancient
Roman ruins just outside its doors it is
a constant reminder of me of the
importance of Baalbek and this is
something that was not accidentally
built here if I wanted to describe the
view in front of me daily when I look
out of the window when I come to the
hotel I'd be speechless and generally
it's hard for me to be speechless the
smell of this hotel is carpets old walls
and rusty faucets but that makes you
smile and this is I think essentially
what memories are all about
the old personnel that has been here
since the 50s and some some of the 60s
have stayed with us because to them it's
home a lot of our idea well they better
reabsorb oh oh she out there somewhere
but other homes Oh marry anybody but you
Oceana pond and this is the feeling that
keeps them going even with tourism
dwindling in this region we've never
closed the doors of the hotel no one has
the right to touch hotel palmera except
for time deep inside the greco-roman
city of Hierapolis lies the most
relaxing and the most visited site in
all of Turkey from a distance Parma
Carla's cascading white pools seem to
resemble a castle of fluffy cotton but
upon closer inspection they reveal
themselves to be solid limestone walls
housing turquoise mineral rich water
the site is fittingly called Parma Carla
which translates to cotton castle in
Turkish housing 17 hot springs
they each range in temperature from 35
degrees to 100 degrees perfect for
soaking in Parma Kalle has been used as
a natural bathing spot for centuries
especially since the water in each hot
spring is filled with minerals it was
the Greek and Romans who discover that
these minerals potentially hold
countless curative properties according
to many the water brings benefits to the
skin eyes and can assist with recovery
from high blood pressure making this
cotton castle a very relaxing place to
visit
you